foreign
[Music]
architecturally
the king of Faso is one of many
developing nations swapping traditional
Earth brick buildings for those made of
concrete and cement while these building
materials are often seen as a sign of
development the reality is quite
different
the construction industry globally
accounts for 38 of carbon dioxide
emissions and building with concrete
makes up around eight percent of that
total
we Architects have to start listening
not just to the climate and to ecology
we seriously have to kind of own up to
the responsibility that's at stake here
I think this is the responsibility of
every future architect to think about
mitigating the damage and to look at the
proper alternatives
Clara sourdogo is one of those
Architects looking for a sustainable
alternative
she's part of a growing movement who
think reimagining how we build with mud
is the solution
often uses Banco also known as Adobe in
her buildings
the compacted sun-dried bricks make use
of whatever can be found in the local
area including soil sand clay stones and
sticks foreign
mud buildings gained a bad reputation in
Burkina Faso after there were several
reports of houses collapsing due to
extreme rainfall
as living standards have increased and
cement has become more easily accessible
people have moved away from using Earth
to build
a consecutions
sourdogo is convinced that mud can not
only withstand changes to the
environment but actually fare better
than concrete
her buildings also challenge the idea of
what mud buildings look like
um
attention
the Nubian vault is a design that was
revived by Egyptian architect Hassan
fatty in the 1940s after he saw the
technique in the Nubian Village of Abu
abrish
it has a curved structure that doesn't
require wood or metal reinforcement
making it environmentally friendly and
ideal for countries with limited natural
resources
foreign
[Music]
this year
Beyond being a recyclable and
sustainable resource Earth is also
better suited to Rising temperatures
mud has a high thermal Mass which means
it slowly absorbs and stores heat during
the day stopping a house from becoming
too hot
then when the temperature drops at night
the heat is radiated back into the room
ultimate
episode foreign
in contrast then cinder block walls with
Hollow recesses allow heat to pass
through much quicker causing the inside
of buildings to get extremely hot during
the day
many people who've built with concrete
are finding they now need to buy air
conditioning units but the cost of
installation and upkeep are too much for
some
our institutions at the moment are
adhered towards this industrial form of
computer type of generated architecture
which is devoid of any sensitivity
devoid of any interaction with nature
devoid of any interaction with the
inhabitants who are going to be living
there let alone the discussion of a
community
as Hassan Fateh used to say we're
interested in the people who have the
melaleem meaning the sense and not in
the people who have the malayin meaning
the millions you know we're talking of
The Wider population because this is
where the impact of the climate and
what's happening in the climate change
is most seen
Burkina Faso contributes just 0.08 of
global emissions but ranks as one of the
country's most vulnerable to climate
change
the landlocked Nation could see a
temperature increase of up to 1.6
degrees Celsius by 2050 and up to 4
degrees by the end of the century that's
two and a half times more than the
global average
we need a paradigm shift
and unless this happens yesterday before
today it's not going to be possible it's
not going to be possible to mitigate the
effects of the carbon footprint and the
damage the damage that we have been
creating there's this balance there's
this ecological balance about the use of
natural building materials that you
don't find anymore this is not the
architecture of the past this is the
architecture of the future
building with mud offers clear
advantages for the environment
especially for those living in hotter
climates but it's not without its
drawbacks creating structures like
sourdogos that are as sturdy as concrete
and look just as modern takes much more
time this makes it difficult to scale up
to match the demands of the modern
building sector
for now Architects are using a hybrid
method combining a small amount of
concrete into their designs which speeds
up the process but also safeguards
against more intense weather events
[Music]
foreign
conception
to phone come the the boot benefits
[Music]